we begin tonight at our southern border
where a report out of sunland park new
mexico claims human smugglers are hiring
teenagers to pick up migrants and drive
them to el paso texas that reuters
report describes how these teens and the
smugglers share their cell phone
location to track each other to their
meeting place cbp says around one in
four drivers caught smuggling migrants
in the area
are underage and while boarding crossers
surge one veteran cbp source says there
simply won't be enough agents to account
for the massive influx expected when
title 42 expires
the agency has continually faced low
morale citing incidents like the one in
del rio texas where agents were accused
of whipping migrants by democrats in the
mainstream media and in this week's
reports
these agents have been completely
cleared of any wrongdoing they were
simply just doing their job trying to
protect our border while the
administration seems to take action that
will only make their job harder
the texas department of public safety
has stepped up to try and fill the gap
as migrants flood to our border i went
down to experience
their difficult job with them take a
look
we just got out of the chopper
trails here
we saw about four different tracks going
different directions so we're trying to
figure out where exactly they're heading
to
these migrants try to get to a road
where a coyote can pick them up so we're
just trying to find the direction
they're heading first
where are you at you couldn't get a good
view from the chopper we kind of
narrowed it down now that we're on the
ground we got all those tracks
we just had two agents join us from
border patrol
um they were tracking them one direction
dps was tracking the different we've
kind of met up now we think they're
going this way we'll have to see
after spending some time on the ground
trying to track the migrants we went
back to the sky in our helicopter to
find exactly where the runners were
heading all it took was a few minutes in
the air before we spotted them huddled
together dressing camouflage trying to
get relief from the desert heat where
did you guys come from
mexico yeah how long have you been on
the road almost a week a week
y'all just got lost yeah
no water
[Music]
just a bag we were tracking these
runners from the helicopter
we saw them huddled up they've been
traveling for about a week but they've
run out of food and they actually got
lost here but because of the chopper
we're able to locate them and they're
just going to surrender themselves after
we gave the migrants some water they
told me they came to america to work and
fled their homes in mexico because of
the growing violence from the cartel
when you got to america who are you
going to stay with
first of all
work work
and then
and we need to figure it out because
mexico is difficult
did y'all have to pay the cartel to come
across
no they they don't know maybe they
didn't know yeah this y'all came across
that's kind of how y'all got lost huh
the kindness is very dangerous they kill
you for nothing and
they don't let you do nothing if you
gotta like i say
if you got
60 000 pesos it's like three thousand
dollars
they won
2 000 and
and every month you got a payment like
two thousand two thousand where are you
going to get that money in mexico mexico
no more
whatever
yeah this is a different mexico no more
mucho problema
that's all you want to do
is they're saying that they came from
mexico that they can't return to mexico
because of the cartel they killed them
and their family they take all their
money all they want to do is come to
america to work one is a butcher one is
a mechanic one is a carpenter they
wanted to surrender themselves they had
no god they're saying they can't return
when they work in mexico they take their
money
they threaten their family while they
may walk away from now the migrants we
encounter will be sent back to mexico
under title 42 but as the situation
worsens in mexico more and more migrants
continue to illegally enter the u.s
and those americans who live on the
border are growing more concerned for
their own safety
as their homes and property are being
violated catherine you're a
businesswoman you've got multiple
properties
why do you care about the border
because the border is impacting me
personally
and then it's also impacting me and my
business but personally is the main main
thing that concerns me i live on 55 000
acres in the middle of nowhere in the
big bend
and it's gone from
you know exercising outside or working
cattle without worrying who's going to
be out there carrying a gun and now i
have to carry a gun when i go play in my
backyard and i don't like that
what do you see
we see paraphernalia we see
tracks
we see
people
coming through i think it's time for
people as myself to step up
as
you know i'm 50 and i think i have
enough education behind me and enough
life
in me to run for an office and make a
difference in life and if i don't step
up and if people like you don't step up
who's going to step up where's our
country going to be hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else